[Music]
hey guys welcome to this complete
angular tutorial
angular is a full-fledged javascript
front-end framework used to create
single-page applications
applications like gmail upwork nike and
forbes among others are built using
angular
now there's a great demand for angular
developers in the market today so if you
wish to learn angular then you're in the
right place
this complete tutorial will introduce to
you the fundamental concepts of this
framework first we'll start off by
understanding what exactly angular is
then i'll help you create a simple hello
world application and teach the basic
file system and libraries of the
application
then we learn about the basic building
blocks of angular that is components
after that we'll dive into advanced
topics like angular dependency injection
forms services angular bootstrap and
angular routing
after that we'll compare angular with
other front-end javascript libraries
like react and view
and lastly i'll present to you angular
interview questions that will help you
crack your next interview
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already
make sure to click the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
in this session we're gonna cover the
topic of what is angular
i'm sure all of you use mobile and web
applications be it from social media to
health care e-commerce and net banking
these apps are used by billions of
people across the globe now the main
reason we use these apps is that they
offer seamless user experience and
interface but how are they developed to
provide such reliability one of the
frameworks that is widely used to build
such robust apps is angular so let's
dive into the session now so here is a
list of topics that we're going to be
covering first up we'll see why angular
was introduced
then what is angular
features of angular angular architecture
advantages and limitations of angular
the learning curve of angular and
finally we'll look at some of the
companies that deploy angular so without
further delay let's begin
why angular now javascript is the most
commonly used client-side scripting
language it is written into html
documents enabling interactions with web
pages in many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost pervasive support
it is exceptionally well suited to
develop modern applications but the
question arises
is javascript ideal for developing
single page applications that require
modularity testability and other
features perhaps not however we have a
variety of frameworks and libraries
designed to help us with such things
with respect to front-end development
angular and javascript together bring in
structure and consistency to your web
applications and also provide
scalability and maintainability
angular is specifically developed for
single page applications so now the
question arises what exactly is angular
angular is an open source javascript
framework written completely in
typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by google
angular as a framework provides a few
advantages while also providing a
standard structure for developers it is
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms if you have a doubt here as to
what exactly single page applications
are let me help you with that now these
single page applications are basically
applications that get loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions does
not lead to loading of subsequent pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already loaded
page so these single page applications
are primarily developed using angular
moving ahead let's look at the features
of angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing
we have the document object model type
script data binding and testing now
let's look at them one by one now the
document object model treats an xml or
an html document as a tree structure
now here every node in the tree
structure defines an object representing
a part of your document
angular uses the regular dom now let's
suppose you've made 10 updates on a
single html page
so every time you make a change the
corresponding dom or the tree structure
needs to be updated
now angular updates the entire tree
structure of html tags
moving on to our next feature
we have typescript
now typescript defines a set of types to
javascript which helps you write
javascript that is easier to understand
now all the typescript code compiles
down to basic javascript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is not mandatory for developing an
angular application but it is highly
recommended the main reason is highly
recommended is that it offers better
syntactic structure while making the
code base easier to understand and
maintain now typescript can be installed
as an npm package
now to do that you just have to run the
command npm install hyphen g type script
on your command prompt next up is data
binding now data binding is a process
that allows you to manipulate web page
elements using the web browser
now it mainly employs dynamic html and
does not require complex scripting or
programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials games etc now incremental
display of a web page makes data binding
extremely convenient when pages contain
a large amount of data when it comes to
angular it uses two-way data binding so
any changes meeting the ui element is
reflected in the corresponding model
state
and conversely any changes made in the
model state are reflected onto the ui
state
this allows the framework to connect the
dom to the model data via the controller
the last feature we're discussing is
testing
angular uses jasmine to run its various
tests the jasmine framework allows
various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases
karma is a task runner for the tests
that use a configuration file to set the
startup reporters and testing framework
so with that we've covered the features
of angular so let's go ahead and
understand
the architecture of angular
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured and
offers bi-directional data flow and
updates to real dom mvc short for model
view controller is an architectural
pattern that separates the application
layer into model view and controller the
model here relates to all the data
related logic view on the other hand is
used for ui logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and view
moving on let's look at the advantages
of angular
first up we have custom components
angular allows you to build your own
components that can pack functionality
along with rendering logic into reusable
pieces
data binding as discussed angular allows
you to effortlessly move your data from
your javascript code to the view and
react to user events without having to
write any code yourself
dependency injection angular allows you
to write modular services and have them
injected wherever they are needed
this greatly improves the testability
and reusability of the same don't worry
if you can't wrap your head around these
topics we're going to discuss them
further in the coming videos
next advantage is testing angular has
been built from the ground up with
testability in mind
you can literally test every part of
your application
comprehensive angular is a full-fledged
framework and provides out-of-the-box
solutions for server communication
routing and more
lastly we have excellent browser
compatibility angular is cross platform
and browser compatible
an angular application can typically run
on all browsers
beat chrome firefox safari and platforms
like windows mac os and linux now many
versions of angular have been released
ever since its inception all of these
versions have added to the efficient
working of the framework now here are
two different versions released first up
was angular 1. it was built on
javascript and completely based on
controllers next release was angular 2.
now this incorporated the component
based approach wherein the entire ui was
divided into several components and
lastly integrated to give the final
logic
next was angular 4 it included router
updation angular cli or command line
interface 1.0 was introduced however not
deployed
in this release the angular cli was
optimized and commands like ng update
and ng add were added
in the angular 7 release prompts were
introduced which provided tips in cli
about the functions being used
in angular 8 iv renderer and bazel were
introduced
and finally the most recent release was
angular 9. now this came with the better
framework and angular material now this
completely switched to the iv renderer
as a default compiler now that we've
learnt about the pros of using angular
let's look at some of the limitations of
angular
first up is a sleep learning curve now
since angular is a complete full-fledged
framework it becomes difficult for
learners to begin with
you need to be acquainted with simple
topics and then move on to more advanced
topics to become proficient in this
language
next up is limited seo options
now angular offers limited seo options
and poor accessibility to search engine
crawlers
it's verbose and complex now a common
issue faced by the angular community is
the verbosity of the framework
it also poses to be complex compared to
other front-end tools
and lastly migration now one of the
drawbacks of angular is poor migration
now it becomes difficult to port legacy
code to angular style architecture
also with each new release it is painful
to upgrade and a lot of them are not
backward compatible
next up let's look at the angular
learning curve
now if you wish to learn angular you
need to be acquainted with basic topics
in angular
some of them are directives
modules decorators components services
dependency injection
pipes and templates
once you've mastered your basics you
will want to go and understand more
advanced topics such as change detection
zones aot compilation and rx.js
however the learning curve of angular is
clear-cut
in the beginning it could be a little
intimidating but once you start using
the tool it becomes way more easier to
comprehend and understand what is going
on
and lastly let's look at some of the
companies that use angular today
many top tier companies like nike
forbes google hbo sony
upwork among others readily deploy
angular so moving on let's look at the
prerequisites for angular
first up we have node.js angular uses
node.js as its base for a large part of
its build environment
so as a result to get started with
angular you will need to have nodejs
installed on your environment so head to
their official website and download the
latest release for your corresponding
operating system
next up is the angular cli now this
command line interface is a tool that
makes it easier to bootstrap and develop
your angular applications now to install
the latest version run the command npm
install hyphen g
at angular
front slash cli you got to run this
command on your command prompt
and finally to confirm installation
check for its version
now the next thing that you will need is
an ide or a text editor to type your
code now there are several ides that you
can choose from but in this series we've
used vs code throughout so it is
available on all platforms so go ahead
and download it if you haven't already
now moving on to the final part is the
demo now that you have a basic
understanding of angular and its
prerequisites i think you're ready to
create your first angular application
so let's head to our vs code and begin
here i've created a folder called
angular on my desktop and opened it on
my visual studio code so to create your
app you need to open the terminal just
go here and
select new terminal
and now type in the command
ng
new
and provide the name for your app so i'm
just going to say hello world
so now this is going to create
just say yes
so basically what happens is that when
you run the command it will
automatically generate a skeleton
application under the folder that is
hello world in our case
and it includes a bunch of files and
installs all the necessary dependencies
for the angular application
so this could take a while
so once you've created your application
to run it first change the directory so
let's say cd
hello world
and now use the command ng serve
now once it's compiled you need to go to
your browser and type in localhost 4200
and once you do that
you can see your ui
you can see that the application has
been loaded onto your browser
and it says hello world app is running
so this is how you create your
application
so let's go back to our vs code now as
you can see here
there are many files and folders that
are created right so let's look at a few
of them of course we can't explain
everything but i'll rush through a few
of them
so the first main component is basically
the root component now the root
component here is the index.html
so here if you open the file and see
it's a very small crisp code right but
the most important thing in the file is
this app root element
so what this does is it's basically the
marker for loading your application code
so this is extremely important so the
next important file is the main.ts
now this is the part of the
bootstrapping piece all right so the
index.html file is responsible for
deciding which files are to be loaded
correct the main.ts file on the other
hand identifies which angular module is
to be loaded when the application starts
so this is just a brief explanation as
to what they are doing
next we have the app folder
now here
we have the
app.module.ts file now this application
module file can be thought of as the
code configuration of your application
so here's where the source code starts
from and moving on we have the
app.component.ts so these are all
typescript files hence the extension ts
now this file basically is the root
component of your application
and then we have the html file for the
same which defines the appearance of
what you can see on your browser so let
me just change the message that is being
displayed
so i'll say hey
welcome to this
angular
tutorial so let's save this
and when we go back to our browser
we can see the message hey welcome to
this angular tutorial being displayed
so like this we can make a simple change
and then it gets rendered onto your
browser so this was just a brief
explanation of what happens in the
background of your application
first
we'll get acquainted to what exactly
angular components are
then i'll help you create an angular
component by showing a quick demo and
lastly we'll learn about component
decorator metadata but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our channel if
you love watching new and interesting
technology videos also hit the bell icon
to never miss an update so what exactly
are angular components
now i'm sure everybody uses web
applications and one of the most widely
used applications is gmail correct now
to help you understand what components
are consider them as lego blocks now
they basically are combined together to
form the final application
so in this case here we have the logo
component then you have a sign in
component an image component and then a
create account component now all of
these components generally don't affect
the working of each other
but however when embedded they define
the ui of your application
so i hope you understood what components
are
so to go ahead let's discuss some of its
common features now firstly they are the
building blocks of an application
generally you have a root component
which is basically the app component and
then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
and these components are a subset of
directives now don't worry about what
deductives are because we'll cover them
later on in the series but to give you
an idea there are three types of
directives you have the structural
directives the attribute directives and
the component directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template now components
are typically custom html elements and
each of these elements can instantiate
only one component
now don't worry you'll understand this
better when i show you the demo
nextly a typescript class is used to
create a component now this class is
then decorated with the at component
decorator now the decorator accepts a
metadata object that gives information
about the component now a component must
belong to the ng module in order for it
to be usable by another component or
application
and finally components control their
runtime behavior by implementing life
cycle hooks
so this was just a brief introduction to
what angular components are
now you will only be able to understand
the working of components when i show it
to you practically so let's head over to
a visual studio code
now here back in my vs code i've created
a folder called angulardemo within which
i've created an angular application
called demo components
once executed the browser looks
something like this
so if you haven't watched our previous
video on getting started with angular
that is angular hello world i highly
suggest you go through that video first
it helps you create your first angular
application so um
now let's go ahead and create our first
component
now the command used to create our
component is ng gc and your component
name
once executed it creates four different
files now let's just see how this works
on rvs code now what you can do is head
to your terminal and type in the command
ng
g
c
and provide a name for your component
for example i'm going to just call my
component text component
all right
so what it does is that it creates four
different files you can see you have
four different files that have been
created and finally it updates the file
that is app.module.t
indicating that this new component has
been created so here in your source
folder
within which there's an app folder and
again here you can see that your four
different files have been created first
is the html file where you can define
all the code that you want for your
component next you have the css file for
your styling
then you have the dot ts file which
includes the component decorator and
finally you have spec.ts which is
basically a unit test file all right and
then in your app.module.ts
you can observe that the component that
you've created that is text component
has been imported that is what the
message conveys here all right now let's
go back to our app.component.html
now this basically has all the code for
your application so let me just get rid
of it
[Music]
and i'm just gonna
display a basic
heading saying
hello
welcome
all right so let me save it
and if you go ahead and look at your
browser
hello welcome message is displayed now
let's go back to our component
dot html file
and here
let me
provide a message
[Music]
let me say h
3
and let me display a message saying
welcome to this tutorial
on angular components
all right
now in your text component dot ts file
which is your typescript file
the selector mentioned here is app
hyphen text component now go ahead and
copy this
and in your final
component.html go ahead and create your
custom html tag with the selector that
you just copied now this indicates that
the component that you just created that
is the text component is being
incorporated in the final render so what
happens is that whatever is defined in
the component.html file is also being
rendered in your final output so when i
save this
let's go ahead and check
our browser you can see that the message
welcome to this tutorial on angular
components is displayed so this was a
simple creation of a component now for
this let's give it some styling
so here go to your dot css file and
provide some styling say for example
here i just say
text line
and let me say center and also in my
app.component.c i'm going to give the
same thing and say each one
text align
is center
all right so let me save this
and there we go
now we can also create multiple
components and define the tags in the
app component now the components are
executed sequentially
so now let's create another component
just to give you a brief insight into it
let's say ng nggc
image component
now here i'm going to be adding the
simply learn logo so i'll show you how
that works
now you can see that a new component has
been created with four files again so in
my assets folder here i've added the
logo
so what i can do is back in my html file
i can go ahead and create an image tag
so first let me just display another
message here
just to avoid any confusion and let me
say this is the image component
[Music]
and then
let me say
image
source
equals so the source is basically assets
[Music]
slash
logo
dot png
and class
equals
center
[Music]
all right so you can also head to your
css file and provide any sort of styling
that you need
so let me just say
text align
to be center
and then let's create
a styling for the image
and here i mentioned the code for the
image
so let's save this and from the dot cs
file
let's copy the selector
and create a custom html tag in our
final component.html file
so there we go
let's save this and check the output
and there we go
first the hello welcome message is
displayed
next you have the message displayed from
the first component and then you have
the second component
so this is how you can create
your own components and don't forget to
incorporate these selectors into your
final html file
so moving on to our next topic component
decorator metadata now as mentioned
earlier the at component decorator
accepts a metadata object that provides
information about the component
correct here is a list of properties of
the metadata object first up is the
selector now basically the selector is a
css selector that identifies this
particular component in a template now
this corresponds to the html tag that is
included in the parent component you can
create your own html tag however the
same has to be included in the parent
component so to help you understand that
better let's head back to our vs code
and say for example in our text
component
here
the selector says text component
correct for the time being let's change
it to say n component
all right now when you save it and look
at the browser
the message is not displayed
so what we can do is you can copy this
selector
and then include this
here
and now you can see
that the same component has been
rendered onto your output
all right so the selector plays a
crucial role in that
next up we have the template now a
template is an inline defined template
for the view now the template can be
used to provide some particular markup
the markup could typically include some
headings or paragraphs that are
displayed on the ui
next up we have template url now it is
the url for the external file containing
the template for the view
so here you can see
this is basically the external file that
contains the template for the view
next up you have styles now these are
also inline defined styles that can be
applied to the components view so any
code that you provide in the dot css
file can also be included here
next you have the style urls now this is
a list of urls to your style sheets that
are applied on your components view
next up you have providers now this is
again an array where certain services
can be registered for your component
lastly we have animations as the name
suggests these are animations that can
be listed for your components
first we'll understand what exactly
dependency injection is
then we'll understand the demerit or the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
then we'll understand dependency
injection as a design pattern and
finally i'll help you understand the
entire concept with the help of a demo
so let's begin
what exactly is dependency injection so
let's consider this i'm sure you're
aware that angular uses the concept of
components the entire ui of the
application is divided into several
components
now what if all of these components
perform similar tasks be it accessing
the database rendering images etc now
instead of writing the same piece of
code for every component you could write
the code once and then perhaps inject
the same code into every component
now this is supported by dependency
injection
now to give you a better example
consider two classes a and b
now let's assume that a uses the objects
of class b
and normally in object oriented
programming an instance of class b is
created so that a can access its objects
but using dependency injection we move
the creation and binding of dependent
objects outside of the class that depend
on them so dependency injection or di
keeps the core more flexible testable
and mutable also classes can inherit
external logic without having to create
on its own and lastly di benefits
directives pipes and components
next up let's have a look at the
drawback of not using dependency
injection now let's consider class
postal details that is dependent on the
number and the address class
in the postal details class the
constructor creates copies of the number
and address so when you instantiate a
new postal details class the constructor
instantiates a unique number and address
now although this looks simple there's a
problem with this code
let's assume that the number and address
class constructors now accept parameters
when we change the numbers class the
postal details class gets broken
now to overcome this what we need to do
is we need to pass parameter to the
number constructor so this applies to
address as well
the first drawback of using this
traditional method is that the code is
not very flexible
anytime the dependencies change the
postal details class needs to be changed
as well
and the second drawback is that the code
is not suitable for testing
once you instantiate the new postal
details class you get the same number
and address even if you change the
number and address classes every time
what if these classes are in turn
dependent on other classes
then it's going to be a chain reaction
so to overcome this we make use of
dependency injection
now let's look at di as a pattern
dependency injection as you all know is
a coding pattern where a class receives
its dependencies from an external source
rather than creating them on its own so
here in the above example we have moved
the definition of dependencies from
inside the constructor to the
constructors parameters
so the postal details class doesn't
create the dependencies anymore
it just consumes them so the postal
dependencies class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
so with that we overcome the drawbacks
of not using di
so now that you know what exactly
dependency injection is and how vital it
is let's look at a simple demonstration
to understand the concept better now
services classes modules competence all
of these are benefactors of dependency
injection so in the demo i'm going to be
showing how dependency injection can be
used with the help of services and
injecting these services into classes so
the main
thought behind this is normally
components are used to ensure just a
good user experience
these components do not generally
execute tasks so to execute these tasks
we make use of services so a component
can delegate tasks like fetching data
from the server any network related
issues etc to a particular service and
these services can be made available to
components
with the same thought what i'm going to
be doing is i'll be creating a service
that performs the task of displaying an
employee list later we're going to
inject the service into the class using
dependency injection
so let's head to our visual studio code
for the demonstration
all right so as discussed i'll have to
first create a component that displays a
button for the employee and then i have
to create a service class and inject it
into my component now this service holds
the employee details such as name
employee id email id etc
so first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here let me just type
ngc
and the name of the component i'm
providing is amp
info
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
all right so as you can see here in my
app folder i have the component
with four different files all right so
the next thing we have to do is we have
to create a service so to create that we
make use of the command
ng g
s
you can either give s or service and the
service name i'm providing is records
so let me just say
records here
all right here you can see two files are
created there is a spec.ts file and the
dot ts file
all right so now the service contains
all the employee data that needs to be
displayed right so let's go ahead and
write the data so first we're going to
make use of three arrays i'm going to be
displaying employee records for three
employees so i'll have to create three
arrays and provide certain information
so let's go ahead and do that
all right so the area i'm creating is
called info one for the first employee
and i'm going to be
passing
information like name employee id and
the email id
so the arrays of type string
and within which let me just mention the
details i'm giving random information
i'm just saying adam taylor
and some random
employee id
and let's say 80 at abc.net
all right so i'm going to be creating
three records so i'll just copy the same
thing and paste for the rest too
let's just change here
provide a different name here
and same for the last one
and
let me change the name of the area as
well
all right so with the agenda to retrieve
this data in our component we make use
of the method for the same right so this
method returns the employee data
so let's go ahead and create this method
i'm going to call it get info
and then just say string
and then this will just return
this dot in four one
all right i'm going to be calling it get
info one for better understanding
same for the rest two as well
i'm just going to return different
arrays here
all right and lastly info 3 all right
now in order to retrieve this
information in our component we need
three more arrays right three more
arrays that will receive this data let's
go back to our component dot ts file
here and then type in the following code
so i've created three arrays again or
info received one two and three
now what we need to do is we have to
accept the information that is being
sent from the service correct
now as
i mentioned services are implemented
with the help of dependency injection so
what we need to do is we'll have to
first import the service into the
component.ts file
the key reason behind doing this is that
when angular creates this component an
instance of the service class is also
made to perform the necessary tasks
correct so let's go ahead and just
import it here
so i'll say import
[Music]
records
services
i'm sorry service
from
and let's say records dot service
all right and what we have to do next is
that we must also declare this instance
that is being created in the providers
area of the component
all right so
let's just say providers
and then say records
service
all right now we've created the instance
of this class
right however to access this instance an
object is also created so this object
will in turn access the methods and
variables of the service class so for
that we have to create another object so
let's do that here in our constructor
method
let's say constructor
private
and the object i'm creating is called
our service you can give a name
of your choice
and then i'm going to just say records
service
all right now this
object will help me retrieve data from
the service so let's go ahead and use
this in order to get the employee
details
all right i've created three different
methods here get info from service class
2 1 and 3 and these methods will
retrieve the data and add it to our
array here that is info received all
right
and lastly
we'll have to create an unordered list
in our html file here we haven't added
anything so let me get rid of this
so now i have to create three different
buttons for three different employees
and when the user clicks on the button
the data is retrieved from the service
and then displayed on the ui
right
so as you can see i've created buttons
for three different employees
and then i've made use of a bootstrap
class called list group info
and then i've
interpolated
info which displays the contents
of the info variable all right now in
order to call the methods in the dot ts
file we have to bind them with the
button
so since it is bound with the click
event every time you click on the button
the information is
displayed
so now the last thing we have to do is
we'll have to create a custom html tag
for the component and then add it to the
main component
so let's just do that
let me copy
this here
and then in my
appcomponent.html let me get rid of this
and then let me just create this
i've just created the custom html tag
for my component
and now just to beautify the code i'll
write a heading
and let's say
employee
details
and then i'll also add the simply learn
logo
say image source
[Music]
i've i've added the image here so let me
just say logo
dot png
i've also added some styling to it
all right so now let me just save this
and have a look at the browser
so here we go we have the logo here and
then employee details heading and then
we have three different buttons created
that is employee one two and three and
when i click on it
the information of the employee is
displayed the name the id and their
email address
so yeah so this is how you can make use
of dependency injection and inject a
service class into a component
dependency injection plays a crucial
role in angular
we'll understand what angular forms are
then we'll look at the different types
of form building supported by angular
next up we'll get acquainted with
features like form control and group
control
and we learn all of this with the help
of a simple demo
so without further ado let's begin
so what exactly are angular forms
now i'm sure every application that you
use comes with certain amount of form
filling correct be it your login
credentials or your sign up forms or any
sort of registration forms etc so forms
are an integral part of a web
application
you need forms to update your profile or
to enter sensitive information or also
to perform any sort of data related
tasks
so now let's look at the different types
of form building supported by angular
first up angular supports two types of
form building
first you have the template driven
approach and second you have the
reactive approach
now let's look at them one by one so
talking about template driven approach
in this method the conventional form tag
is used to create forms
so angular automatically interprets and
creates a form object with the help of
the directives
now controls can be added to the form
using the ng model tag
now multiple controls can be grouped
using the ng control group module so it
basically uses several module classes to
provide controls
now if you don't get this don't worry
you'll understand better when i'm
showing you the demo
next up is json values so form value can
be generated using the form dot value
object
form data is exported as json values
when the submit method is called
lastly basic html validations can be
used to validate the form fields in the
case of custom validations directives
can be used so arguably this method is
the simplest way to create an angular
form
so moving on to the active approach now
this approach is the programming
paradigm revolving around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactive forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
now reactive forms are code driven
unlike template driven approach
reactive forms eliminate the anti
pattern of updating the data model via
two-way data binding
so it does not use two-way data binding
and typically a reactive form control
creation is synchronous and can be unit
tested with synchronous programming
techniques
so now let's go ahead and look at form
control and form group
so consider a typical form consisting of
fields like name age and location now a
form control is basically a class that
enables validation of these fields
for each input field an instance of this
class is created now these instances
help check the values of the field and
see if they are either touched untouched
dirty pristine valid invalid and so on
so this allows you to check every field
for the value it makes it easier to
understand which field's value is
invalid or which field has not been
entered etc
now moving on to form group
so a form group class represents a group
of controls a form can have multiple
group controls the form group returns
true if all the controls are valid and
provides validation errors if there are
any so i hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the demo
to explain all of these features i'm
sure it will become extremely clear once
you look at the demo
so for that let's head to our vs code
so back in my vs code
i've created a component called form
component
and um i've also included the simply
learn logo just to beautify the
appearance so once you execute the code
this is what you're going to see on your
browser
so you just have the logo at the moment
the first thing we need to do is we'll
have to
import the forms module all right
so oh uh but before we begin let me tell
you what the use case is so we're going
to be creating a user registration form
which is going to include four fields
that is the first name last name email
id and a password
all right so now let me show you how to
import the forms module so in your main
app.module.ts file
you will have to import forms module
from angular forms
all right and then in your imports
you'll have to just call it here
all right so this is just a simple step
and now once you're done with that
let's go ahead and
start our form creation
so here in my component.html
let's enclose the entire form within a
div tag
so here
let me say div
class
is a container
within which let me just have one
heading
it says user registration
all right and now let's go ahead and
create our form
so first let me just say form
now i'm going to create a div class for
every field
so
say div
class
equals form group
i'll explain it to you a little later
now first let's create a label
so label tag
for
basically it's the first name
so let me just say first name
and the tab will basically have
first name again
all right and let me just break the line
next we have the field so let's say
input
type is text
name is
first name
and we have a class which is
the form control class
all right so this we have to do for all
the other fields
so let me just copy this
and
paste it like four times
i'll also add the tag 3
for spacing
let's do that here
and finally we'll have the button
[Music]
so let's just add that here
with a type submit
and let's just say submit on the button
so now let's go ahead and change these
values here
so here let me just change it to last
name
here as well
and here as well
and in this case it is going to be email
so let me just change it here
and finally we have password so
let's add that here
all right so let's save this and just
have a look at our browser
so there we go we have our
user registration form ready but i would
like to uh align it to the center so let
me just do that
so here in my css file
i'm just going to uh
align all the div tags to the center and
the label tag to the left so let me save
this and look at the browser now
and there we go we have a registration
form with a logo so this is how you
create a simple form
now we have to add a directive called ng
model
now this directive when added into the
input tag
will
provide form controls to every input
field
all right so here let's just go ahead
and say ng
model
that is it
so let me just copy this and paste it
for every other field
all right let me save this
and back in my browser
let me inspect
and here you can see different types of
classes like ng untouched ng pristine
ng ballet are added
right so this indicates that angular has
recognized the form tag and it has added
these classes to the form as well as all
the fields so this is achieved when you
add the ng model directive in your input
tag now
back in my vs code
now every form has an output property
attached to it called ng submit all
right so this property can be bound
within a method that method called the
subbit method
so once submitted this method is called
right so once we click on the submit
button this method has to be called so
to include that
we'll have to just save
form
ng submit
equals
submit
[Music]
all right so now we have to define the
submit method
in our component.ts file so here let me
just go to our component.ts file and let
me
just get rid of unnecessary code here
and let's define a function
called subnet
and then here let me just
console.log
form submitted
all right so let me just get rid of this
as well it's unnecessary here
let's save this so what it means is that
every time you click on the submit
button
this method is called all right so let's
just have a look at the browser so first
let's go to our console
and when i click on submit it says form
submitted
all right so the next crucial step is to
generate javascript representation now
we'll have to make use of another
directive called ng form
that is assigned to a template variable
okay so
this javascript representation helps
with validating all the fields so i'll
help you understand that better
so back in our html file
let's just create a variable first
let's call it login
all right
and say ng
form
okay
now the mgform object includes the
javascript representation so now while
you're calling the submit method you're
going to pass login as a parameter
so let's just say login here
and in my ts file
again let's just say login
and along with it
i want login to be displayed so
i say login again
so now let's save this
and if you have a look at the browser
let's click on submit
and now here you can see the javascript
representation
so
within form
i can
check
for
email
or say first name and here for this
field first name you can see different
properties attached you can see invalid
is it invalid or is it
untouched
which is true or are there any errors so
this basically gives you all information
about the particular field
so we can make use of this feature to
validate the information so we're going
to learn about that in our next segment
moving on to form validation one way to
ensure that incorrect fields are not
submitted is by disabling the submit
button
correct now apart from this you can also
specify certain properties in your input
tag for the corresponding input field
now um
let's say that the fields that
now let's say that the fields can't be
empty
and the form only accepts names with the
minimum length of 2 and the maximum
length of 7
all right so here in my input tag
i just mentioned required
meaning this field cannot be empty
and min length
to 2
and
max length
to say 7
all right
so to check this
let's go to our browser
and here
let me submit the form without filling
the first name
and evidently there has to be an error
so when i submit it
and i look here
what's in forms and here controls
and my first name
you can see that
an error is shown here it says
required equals true
that means that there is one error
now you can make use of these form
control objects
you can leverage form control objects to
ensure field validation and display a
message whenever an error occurs
right so to do that you need to access
these objects like errors or invalid
or touched all of these properties or
objects need to be accessed for that
we'll have to create a template variable
and then this variable is assigned to
this object
so back in our vs code
let's create
a variable
let me call it
name
and
let's say
ng
model
all right here the variable name
receives the control
object
so here back in my browser when i submit
again without
the first name
you can see that the invalid
property
is set to true
correct so this helps us use this
property to alert the user with the help
of a simple if logic
so back in my
vs code
let me create another
div tag
within which i mentioned ng if
within which i'm going to use a simple
if logic
so let's say ngf
name which is our template variable
name
dot touched
and
name dot invalid
is true
right then i'm going to alert
so i'm gonna
make use of an alert
here let's say
alert
danger
all right
so in my css file i'll have to
mention the simple styling for alert
so here let me just say
so we're going to have the background
color red
for
danger all right and here i'm going to
display the message
invalid in bold
so now let's go back to our browser and
check it
so let me proceed without entering the
last name it says invalid here
so this was a simple demonstration to
show you form validation
of course you can modify the code
depending on your requirement
say suppose the length of the first name
is too short then you can alert the user
with a different message or
suppose they have missed out on filling
a form field then you can again alert
the user so you can basically make use
of the nested if condition right now
just try and help you understand that
better let me just show it to you
now back in my html
file instead of invalid let me have
another
tag a paragraph tag
within which i make use of ngif again
now ngf
name dot errors
[Music]
dot required
is true
then i display the message
first
name
required
all right
and
if
the length of the first name is
not two
now if the length of the first name is
less than 2 then i'm going to display
another message so let me just say
name dot errors
dot min length
if this is true then i'm going to say
sorry
short
first name
all right so let's save this and have a
look at the browser
when i proceed without providing the
name it says first name required
but when i type in one character it says
sorry short first name but if i type in
another character it accepts so i hope
this made you understand how form
validation works
so this was just a simple demonstration
again now i highly recommend you explore
these properties and play around with
these objects uh trust me it's really
fun
so i hope this tutorial helped you out
i'm sure you all know that an angular
app is divided into several components
for example you have the logo component
you have the sign in component an image
component and say a create account
component
now these components are standalone and
each of them represents a part of the
user interface
now imagine if all of these components
performed common tasks for example
accessing the database
or rendering images on the view
tasks like those
now instead of having to write the code
for every component
you can just make use of angular
services
now the service can be written once and
they're injected into all of these
components
now a service could be a function it
could be a variable or a feature that an
application needs
so the main use of a service is to write
code once and avoid rewriting of it
now the same code can be injected into
several components that make use of this
particular service
but what are angular services
so normally components are used to
ensure a good user experience now that
is the extent of it components make sure
that whatever is being rendered onto the
screen is right and pristine
but in order to execute tasks we make
use of services and this approach is
ideal
so a component can basically delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
validating user input or logging
directly to the console to a particular
service
and these tasks can be made available to
any component in the app
so now let's talk about a few features
of angular services
now typically an angular service is
simply a typescript class with an at
injectable decorator
this decorator tells angular that the
class is a service and can be injected
into components that need that service
now they can be used to share the same
piece of code they can also inject other
services as dependencies
now these services hold valuable
business logic
and can also be used to interact with
the back end
now for example if you want to make ajax
calls you can have methods to those
calls in the service and then use it as
a dependency in files
and as mentioned earlier it can be used
to share data among several components
in angular services are singleton
meaning that only a single instance of a
service gets created and the same
instance is used by each and every
building block in the application and
finally a service can be registered as a
part of a module or it can be registered
as a part of the component now to
register it as a part of the component
you'll have to specify it in the
provider's array of the module
i'm sure you'll understand the concept
of services better if we look at a
simple demo
so in the next section we're going to
look at a demo but before that let me
tell you the use case
so basically in the demo what we'll do
is we'll create an employee details list
say for example you will have employee
information like name employee id and
their email id will create a database of
say three employees
and on the browser when you click on the
employee button it displays the
information about that particular
employee
and at the end we can also add
information to the employee's details so
without delay let's head to our vs code
and start learning angular services
hands-on so here first i've created a
folder called demo underscore angular
within which i've created a file called
hello world so this was previously used
for a tutorial so the name is just hello
world so don't get confused
however when you
look at the browser i've written
an initial code here
which is angular services and i have the
simply learn logo
so back in my browser this is what the
ui looks like
so uh to
so to understand the concept of angular
services
first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here i'm going to say ng
g c
e info
i'm creating a component for employee
information
so as you can see
inside my app
file we have the e info
component which has these four files
so if you're wondering what exactly
components are and how this is working
then i highly suggest you watch our
components video first
so now let's go ahead and create a
service
so i'm just typing in the command ng
g
service
here g stands for generate
and we're generating a service and the
name of the service that i'm providing
is data
so now it creates a service
which is going to be
a dot ts file
so you can observe that dot service is
appended this indicates that it is a
service
all right
as mentioned earlier we have to display
the employee details correct so for that
in my
file i'm going to create an array
that displays the employee information
in our case i'm creating uh three
different employee records so for that
i'll have three different arrays
so let me just call the arrays info
received
1 indicating this is the information of
first employee
and this is going to be of type string
and i'll just initialize it to null
for now
all right and i'm going to create
two other
arrays
and let me just
change
the name of that is all right
so now uh to retrieve the information
i'll have to create a method again i'm
creating three methods for uh the three
different employee records so i'm gonna
call the array get
info
from service
one
indicating it's again for employee one
and
i'm just gonna leave it as it is for now
i'll tell you how the information is
being received
and i'm gonna do the same for the other
two uh employee records
so let me just
copy paste and here
i'm just going to change
the name of the methods
all right
so this is the initial code for
retrieving information
however we'll have to create the
employee record in our service
so back here in my data.ts file
what i'm going to do is
i'll create
three different records
for the employees
so let me say info 1
which is going to be of type string
all right
and
let me just give a random names say for
example i say john
matthew
[Music]
all right
and
employee id say
e
354
and let me just give a random
email id and say jm at abc.net
all right so i'm gonna do the same for
the other two uh records
so let me just create another one and
call it info two
and the name i'm providing is say rob
wilson
with a different employee
id say 673
and i'm just going to make it
rw at abc.net
and another record
for employee number three
and
i'm just gonna say rose adams
with
some employee id
and
an email id all right
so now we've created the employee
records
so what i have to do is i have to create
a method
that returns these employee records
correct so for that i'm just going to
create another method called get info 1
which is of type string
and it just returns
this
dot info 1
all right
similarly for the rest of the two
records i'm just going to retrieve them
[Music]
let's say in 4 2
and get info
2. and again
i'm just going to make it get in for 3
and this is going to return
info 3
all right so i'm sure you've got an idea
as to what i'm doing here so basically
this information is going to be
retrieved in our employee component
correct so for that i'll have to make
use of dependency injection so here i'll
have to import the service that i've
created so let's go ahead and say import
[Music]
the service was data service
all right
from
[Music]
slash data dot service all right
now the main reason we're doing this is
to tell angular that when the component
is created
the service instance is also created and
this instance is being used to perform
particular tasks
and for that we also have to include
this in our providers area
so here
let me just say providers
[Music]
and let's say data service
now to access this instance of service
that is created we make use of a
property
so this property basically allows us to
access all the methods that are defined
in the service class
all right
so here in my constructor method i'm
just going to say
private
and you can give any name for your
property and here i'm just giving the
name d service
all right
and which is of type
data service
all right
so now with the help of this property i
can retrieve information from the
service
class so here i'm just going to save
this
dot
info receipt
equals this dot
d service
dot
get info one
all right so what it basically does is
that it calls the get info one method in
our service which returns the
information of the first employee
and this information is being stored in
the array that is info received one
so similarly for the next
two methods i'm just going to use the
same piece of code
let me just change it here
and same for the third one
all right
so now that we have the logic behind
what is being displayed
let's go ahead and create the ui for it
here in my html file
i'm going to create
an unordered list
[Music]
and now i'm going to make use of
the
ng
for director
to basically loop over the record and
display everything
so for that i have to make use of a
particular variable so i'll just say
let info
[Music]
of
info received
so
you can check here in our ts file the
array is info received correct so i'm
going to make use of the same array here
and since it's displaying the first in
employee record i'm just going to
say
info received one
all right and let me just create a class
a bootstrap class of list
group
item of list group info
and we're just gonna have to interpolate
info
all right that is basically going to
display what the information holds what
the info variable holds
all right and here is where let me
create a bootstrap class
called list
group
all right i hope this was clear to you
so basically here
the information is being retrieved with
the help of this method right that is
get info from service one
so in order to call this method we'll
have to bind it with a button all right
so that's what we're going to do
let's just
copy this and here i'm going to create a
button
all right
and the type
is button
[Music]
with name
button again
all right so i'm going to bind it with
the click event
so what happens is that when i click on
it
this particular method gets called
all right i'm just pasting the method
here
and finally let's just provide the name
employee 1
for the button
all right
so similarly we'll have to do the same
for
the other two records as well
let me just make this look better all
right
so what i'm gonna do is i'm just gonna
paste the same
twice
and here i'm gonna just change the names
i'll say 2 here
and this is again for employee 2
and i'm going to change this as well
it's going to be employee i'm sorry it's
going to be in 4 received 2
this is going to be in 4 received 3
and finally employee 3
all right
and lastly we'll have to include
the selector that is app hyphen e info
in our main
component
or html so here
let me just
create a custom tag all right and save
this so now let's go back to our browser
and see what it looks like
so here you can see that three different
buttons have been created
for employee one two and three and when
you click on it
it retrieves information that is
the name the employee id and their email
ids so we've successfully created an
angular service and injected it into our
component to retrieve information all
right so now the last part of the use
case that we discussed was uh to add
another
detail that is the employee detail in
the record
all right so for that we'll have to take
uh input from the user and in our case
we're taking the location
now we're also adding the same location
for all three employees
so this is what services do you know
they can be used to update modify alter
anything that happens in the back end so
you can tweak the code a little bit
and you can change the entire uh view of
your application you can add information
you can delete you can retrieve you can
alter etc all right so for that what
we're going to do is back in the html
file we'll create a form
that basically takes the input
so i'm just going to say
[Music]
form
all right
within which i'm going to be defining a
div class
[Music]
within which i'm going to be defining a
div tag
inside of which i'll have
the input tag
of
type
text
and
the name i'm going to be providing it
will be location
all right
[Music]
and we'll have a value and i'll just
leave it blank and finally i'll have ng
model so if you're confused as to what
i'm doing here then i suggest you watch
the angular forms
video it basically teaches you uh how to
work around with angular forms
all right and now after this we're gonna
have a button
so let me say button
[Music]
all right
[Music]
and i'm gonna just say add
info
okay
all right so now when i'm creating the
form i'll also have to create a
template variable to access all the
values within my form
so if i have to access the location then
i need a variable to access it so here
let me just go ahead and create a
template variable let me call it
frm and i'm going to make use of the ng
form directive
so this tells angular
that
this variable can be used
to
access all the values within the form
and since i'm using form here
i'll have to import it in my
module
file
so here
i just go ahead
and say
import forms module from angular forms
and here in my imports
[Music]
i'll just say forms
module
okay so i've imported the forms module
so now uh back in my html file
what i'm gonna do is that i'll have to
make use of this template variable
to update my information correct
so i'll have to create another method
that will update information into the
records
so here in my component.ts file i'll
have to create another
method
and i'm going to call this method update
info method
all right
and
this basically takes in the template
variable that is form
and let me just specify any
okay and what this is going to do
is that it updates
the record correct so i'm going to say
this
dot
d service
dot
add info
now you must be wondering what ad info
is
i'll just let you know in a minute and
and the value that i'm going to be
passing will be the value that you've
provided as an input which is nothing
but form
dot value dot location
all right so now
what happens is that i'll have to again
specify what add info is and this method
is going to be defined in the service
file correct
so here
i'm going to create another
method that's add
info
and i'm going to pass info as a
parameter
and what this method does is that it
just pushes the information or the data
into the arrays
so since i'm going to be pushing the
same information into all of these
arrays that is info one in photo and
info three i'm just going to say this
dot info one dot push
off info
[Music]
all right and uh the same for
the other two areas as well
let me just
change these all right
so what exactly i'm doing is that i have
i have a method called add info which
gets information from the component
all right and it basically pushes this
information into the array and also i
have to return it so i'll say return
this dot info
[Music]
one
all right
and i'll save it
and here we have another method called
update info which basically calls
uh the add info method in our service
and passes the value to it and in my
html file
also note that the button type here is
submit
and not button
so what happens is that
now the value that we've received as an
input has to be
passed on to the method that is update
info so here
i'll say ng submit
and
i'm going to call the method update
info
and i'm going to pass
frm
as
the argument
and now let's save this
and execute
all right here you can see that we have
an input field and a button saying add
info
so now i can just go ahead and see type
usa
and when i say add info
and when i check on my
employee 1 details usa has been added to
the list
and same goes with employee 2 and
employee 3.
so i hope this simple demo on angular
services helped you understand the
concept better i highly recommend you
play around and explore other
possibilities
let's understand what exactly is
bootstrap
bootstrap is a powerful toolkit
basically a collection of html css and
javascript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications and
pages it is a free and open source
project based on github and originally
created by twitter
now to put it more easily bootstrap is a
giant collection of handy reusable bits
of code written in html css and
javascript
it's also a front-end development
framework that enables developers and
beginners to design quick and responsive
websites
now there are several advantages to
using bootstrap
to name a few bootstrap comes with a
responsive grid
you don't have to spend time working on
your layouts
bootstrap comes with its own code for
automatically resizing images based on
the current screen size
it also comes with different components
that you can use for your web page
these components could be navigation
bars drop downs progress bars thumbnails
etc
it also offers excellent documentation
and is customizable
so bootstrap comes in extremely handy to
create responsive
user interface
so now before using bootstrap it needs
to be embedded into your application
so let's see how to embed bootstrap into
angular
now there are two ways to do it
first up is by using the bootstrap cdn
or the content delivery network
now this enables users to load css
javascript and images remotely from its
servers
the other method is to use bootstrap npm
bootstrap jquery and other packages and
frameworks can be installed via the
command prompt
in the tutorial that i am going to be
showing you i have embedded bootstrap
using npm all right so i'm sure you'll
only understand the concept better when
you look at a demo
so let's go ahead and create an
application with the help of angular
bootstrap so in this tutorial what i'm
going to be showing is the creation of a
blog post
so let me show you what we're going to
be doing
so here i've created a simple
blog
for simply learn and i've added the
simply learn logo i've also written a
few lines about simply learn and what
they offer
i've also mentioned their tag line and
when you scroll down you can see that
i've mentioned the different courses
they're offering
and when you click on the more info
button
it navigates to the official page that
gives you the overview for that
particular course
so this is for lean six sigma the same
for full stack web development
as well
and uh the same for the last one that is
cyber security
and finally i've added a simple video
here to just make it more
beautiful so i've added a simple video
and lastly i've also
linked our youtube channel so when you
click on the youtube icon
it will navigate to the
youtube channel
to our youtube channel here
all right so this is what we're going to
be creating
uh using angular bootstrap so i'm
hoping you're all ready for it so
without further delay let's jump in
so first let's find the template that we
want to use for our blog
so for that i'm going to just go ahead
and say
bootstrap
blog template
and i'm just going to click on the first
link that i get
and here
you can choose the template that you
like
so i'm just going to look for more
templates here
and the one that we are going to choose
is
oh yeah this one so which is small
businesses so you can go ahead and click
on that
you can then click on live preview
and once you do that
you can just
say view frame source
so here you can see that the html code
is available
it has the head section and then the
body section
so the head section consists of a lot of
meta tags and then you have the title
and then you also have the css file
references
and then if you look at the body tag you
have different code for different parts
of the
ui there's code for navigation bar and
then you have page content code
heading row
call to action and all of that
and lastly you have the footer
so what we're going to be doing is that
we'll take all of the code and then
we'll have to create components for each
of it and then we'll include all the
components in our main
html file
so that is the best practice that
angular uses so we're going to make use
of components
and you can also see that
when you scroll down you can see that it
has certain dependencies so here it has
the bootstrap dependency and then you
have jquery so we'll have to
download them
so we'll have to install them
and as mentioned earlier we're going to
be installing them with the help of npm
so for that we'll have to head back to
our vs code here
back in my vs code i've created a
folder called angulardemo
and then i've also created a file called
demo components
and here
i'm just going to say cd
demo components
within which i'll say npm
install
jquery
[Music]
so this could take a while
and once you've installed jquery go
ahead and type npm install
bootstrap
[Music]
all right so we've successfully
installed jquery and bootstrap
so now we need to add the references to
these javascript files to do that
go to your
angular.json file
and here we have to add them in our
build section so here you can see we
have styles and scripts so in our
scripts array we define the relative
path to these javascript files
so these files are generally uh stored
in your node modules so go ahead and
here you can look for bootstrap
here you go and
then in your dist file
and then click on js
and then you can see you have
bootstrap.min.js
oh well i'm sorry we need
bootstrap.bundle.min.js so here
you can just right click and say copy
relative path
and back in my json file in my scripts
i'm gonna just paste it here
and make sure to uh
make it a path by providing by providing
forward slash
[Music]
all right and then the next thing we
need is the
jquery.min.js files so for that
again in our node modules you will have
to look for jquery so here there's
jquery and then click on dist
and then we have jquery.min
so again let me just
copy the path
and paste it here
[Music]
follow the same procedure for this as
well
all right so we've embedded both our
files in our
angular.json file
so now in our code here
in the beginning they've also included
the css file
so we'll have to embed that as well so
here back
in
bootstrap
let me just add the css file as well
that's
bootstrap.min.css i'm just going to copy
the relative path
and just provide it here
[Music]
let me just change these
to forward slash
[Music]
okay so we have our custom style sheet
so what i'm going to do is
i'm just going to copy this
and just paste it in our
[Music]
and then you can just paste it here
all right
so i think we've added all the
dependencies
and the custom style sheet and
everything so now let me just
close all of these files
what we can do now is that we can go
ahead and
take the code from the
source here so i'm just going to copy
the body tag
all right
so
i'm going to copy this till the footer
and then i'm just going to paste it in
my
component.html file
[Music]
so as mentioned earlier i will create
components and then place the code for
specific parts of the ui in these
components
so
let me just see if i've got everything
here
okay
so i'll be creating four components the
first one will be for the navigation bar
the second will be for the introduction
and then the third one will be
to display the courses that we're
providing
and then lastly we'll have the footer
component
right so first let's create these
components i've also created a
components folder here in my app folder
so i just have to
type in the command
ng ggc
first we'll create
the
component for the top navigation bar so
i'm just saying nggc so i'm just going
gonna say components
[Music]
slash nav bar
[Music]
all right so uh the component has been
created so what i'm going to do is i'll
just
copy this
[Music]
and paste it here
[Music]
all right and the next component i'm
going to be creating is for
the introduction right so i'll say ng
g
c
[Music]
components slash
intro
all right so
so i will have to take
this code here i'm also going to be
including the call to action part so
i'll just
copy paste this one in my
intro.html file
[Music]
so let me do that and then i'm going to
have the main course content
component so for that i'll say nggc
components slash courses
[Music]
and we're going to copy the next part of
the code
[Music]
all right until
till the footer
[Music]
let me just add it here
and finally we're going to create the
component for the footer so
i'll say ng gc
components slash
footer
and the last part of the code i'm just
going to add it there
[Music]
all right
so now we'll have to create the custom
html tags for these components and then
place it in our html file right so first
one that we created was the navigation
bar so here
head over to the ts file
just copied the selector
[Music]
and then your and then in our
app.component let me just
create the tags
similarly for intro
[Music]
just gonna copy the selector
[Music]
and then for courses
so
yeah app hyphen courses
that is well
and then lastly we have the footer
component so let me just copy that
paste it here
all right so we've included all the
components so let's just run this
application and see if everything
is displayed intact
so here let me just say ng
serve so when you execute the command
you can see that the template is being
displayed
so you have the navigation bar you have
the
intro component and then we have the
courses component and finally we have
the photo component right okay so now
that we have the template ready we can
go ahead and customize it according to
our needs so now i'm going to be making
a few changes to the code we're going to
add the simply learn logo we're going to
change the tag line here you're going to
display something else over here all
right so let's go back to our vs code to
customize
and display the final output
so here
the first thing that i'm going to be
doing
is changing the message here i'm gonna
display simply learn for that
in our navbar component
let's go to the html code
and here instead of start bootstrap let
me just type in simply learn
[Music]
all right
so when you save it and when you look at
the browser
you can see that
simply learn is displayed
and the next thing that i want to do is
i want to add the image right i simply
learn logo
so what i've done here is i've already
added
the logo
dot png file in my assets folder
so i'll just go ahead and provide the
path to this
so that's going to be in our intro files
so here
image source
is going to be
[Music]
assets
slash
[Music]
logo.png
so let me save this
so there we go the logo is displayed
so the next thing is we'll have to
change
this part of the
ui so the information that i want to
display is this
i'm going to be displaying
walls number one online bootcamp and
other information so what i'm going to
do is back in my vs code
i'm just going to delete
this
and instead of that i'm just gonna
copy this that's world's number one
online bootcamp
and then within the paragraph tag i'll
display something else so let me get rid
of this
[Music]
let me just copy the information that i
want to display
paste it here
[Music]
and let me just give a line break
let me save this and see if it's
displayed
so yeah we can see that the information
is being displayed
next up here instead of displaying call
to action message i'm going to display a
explore programs message so let's go
back to our vs code
let me just say explore
programs here
and then
lastly
instead of this message here
i want to display the message get
certified get ahead without programs
so back in our vs code
i'm just going to get rid of this
[Music]
and paste this instead
so when you
have a look at the browser
let me refresh this
you can see it displays the message get
certified get ahead and all of that
uh well now what i'm going to do is i'm
really not happy with the font size and
everything so i'm just go ahead and add
certain styling you can customize this
and provide your own font size and all
of that
so here i'm just going to mention style
and then say font
size
and i'm going to make it x x large
all right so let's see
[Music]
yeah all right so it's the font size has
increased so i think i'm happy with this
all right so the next thing we have to
do is add information here for our
courses
so back in our vis code
we'll have to go to the courses
component
so here i'm going to just
type in the code for the different
courses so i already have it here
so the first thing is this message that
i want to display let me just copy that
and for our first tag i'm just gonna say
post graduate program ending six sigma
and the next information i'm gonna be
providing is the duration
so here let me just get rid of this
paste that here
let me just break the line
to beautify the
code
and then
and here for our reference link i
already have the link here
so i'm just going to paste that so once
you click on the
more info button it will automatically
navigate to this page
all right
so let me save this
next up i'm going to do the same for the
other two courses as well
so it says postgraduate program in full
stack development
and then we're going to mention the
duration and the cohort so
let me paste that
and also
provide a blind break
and then
link i have it here so
i'm just going to paste that
[Music]
and finally for the third card
i have
the third link here
[Music]
let me get rid of this extra core and
paste this instead
[Music]
and then let's also provide the link for
the same
[Music]
all right
so let me save this
and have a look at the browser
so you can see that
the information has been added you can
see it displays postgraduate program in
lean six sigma full stack development
and cyber security so once i click on
more info it leads you to that
page
that shows the overview all right so now
the next thing on the agenda was to uh
display a short video and then the link
to our youtube channel
so let's go ahead and add that in our
courses component
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to get the code to add a video
from google and then i'm going to uh
provide the source uh which is going to
be the video that i want to display
so i've received the code i'm just going
to paste it here
so you can get the code uh on google so
go ahead and just paste that
also for the source i have a video in my
assets folder which i have provided here
so when i save it and look at the
browser here we go you can see the video
here
all right
and once clicked it starts playing
[Applause]
[Music]
all right and lastly we'll have to
provide the logo for youtube and then
the link to navigate to the youtube page
so let's go ahead and do that
so here again i've pasted the code for
the youtube logo so here you can see
that i've added the image that is
youtube.png in my assets folder and i've
provided the source
and accordingly i've also added
the styling i've provided a white
background and i've also aligned the
text to the
center of the page
all right and i've also displayed the
message saying check out our youtube
channel for technical videos and
tutorials
and then i provided the link to our
channel on youtube
so let me just save this and head back
to the browser
and here you can see that
we have the youtube
logo
and we have the message displayed so
once you click on the
logo it navigates to the simply learn
channel on youtube
all right so
if you want you can also change the
message here for the footer
so here in
footer.html i can just
remove this and
paste this i say simply on solutions and
all rights reserved when i save it and
look at the browser
it must get updated
so yeah there we go so with the help of
bootstrap we have successfully created a
website which is basically a blog
and we've also added the reference links
and images and logos to customize it
according to our requirements
so yeah this is it this is how you uh
make use of bootstrap and embed it into
your angular for more responsive and
better user interface let's have a look
at the basics of routing
now i'm sure that you observed that the
url changes every time you click on a
particular link or on an icon on the
user interface correct now this
basically indicates that you are
navigating throughout the application
now to achieve this navigation we use a
mechanism called routing routing is
essentially used to navigate through a
website or a web application
but how is it achieved in angular
especially in angular routing plays a
major role it is used to create single
page applications
now these applications are loaded just
once and new content is added
dynamically
applications like google facebook
twitter and gmail are a few examples of
single page applications the best part
of using single page applications is
that it provides an excellent user
experience and you don't even have to
wait for new pages to load which by
extension makes single page applications
extremely fast but how is this new
content loaded
enter routing now routing is the
mechanism that as discussed earlier that
is used to navigate through the
application and load new content
routing helps angular configure the
route and the component that needs to be
displayed
now i'm sure you're going to understand
the concept of routing better when you
work on it hands-on
so in the demo we're going to be
navigating to the login and the home
pages of a web application with the help
of routing
so let's head to our visual studio code
so basically the objective of our
application
is to navigate to home
and the login pages
so when i click on the login icon here
it loads the login
page
and here you can see the extension
slash login and similarly with home once
you click on it
some new information gets added and the
url changes
with the slash home appended
all right so this is the main objective
of our application so to create it let's
head back to our vs code all right so
here i've created a folder called demo
and underscore angular and i've created
a file called demo routing
now the first thing you want to do is
open the index.html file and make sure
that the base tag is added
now although this is generally
added when your app is created if it is
not then add a base tag with href
attribute which is set to a forward
slash
all right now this is generally done to
tell angular to construct the url while
navigating with a forward slash alright
and the next thing you want to do is
open your
app.module.ts file
and check if the app routing module has
been imported
if not go ahead and import it and then
also mention it in your imports array
with that the initial setup is done
now to create the nav bar the code that
i'm going to be using is already
explained in the previous video that is
angular bootstrap i highly suggest you
go through that video before watching
this
so the code is already available i'm
just going to create a component and
write the code for it
and paste the code in it so let's do
that
let me say
nggc
navbar
[Music]
all right so this component is now
created
now here in my html file
i'll just get rid of this and paste the
code for the nav bar
so here we go i've pasted the code for
the navigation bar
and back in my
app.component.html file
i'll just remove all the
unwanted
code here
and just specify the
custom html tag for my nav bar
so
let me just create one here
all right let me save this let me just
run the application and see if it's
displaying correctly
all right so when i open the browser
the navigation bar has been created
along with
these different options that's home
about services and login
all right and we also have the simply
learn icon here all right now the next
step is to generate the components to
display the login page content and the
home page content
now again i have used bootstrap to
define the user interface for these
files you can easily find the code
online just search for
bootstrap login templates and depending
on your requirements you can choose the
appropriate one
so first let's create
the components for by two files that is
for the home component
and the login component
so
let's go ahead and do that
[Music]
ngc
i'm just going to call it login
for my login component
all right and then i'm gonna say nggc
home for the home component
all right
so i'm just going to copy the
code for the login component
so back in my login.html
file
i'll just paste the code here
okay
also note that i've added the simply
learn logo in my assets folder
and then just provided the source for it
here in my login component
all right
so next up is the home component
and if you've seen the previous video
that is angular bootstrap you might have
seen that we created three different
components that is intro courses and
footer which included the content for
the intro message for the courses and
the photo message
correct so here we're going to just
paste the code for all of these three
and then just display it when the home
button is clicked
all right so what i'm going to do is
i'll just
paste it here
so this basically has all the content
one thing i want to tell you is that in
the previous video we made sure that the
code was written in three different
components however for this i've just
added all the code in the same component
now i agree that this is not the best
practice so if you want you can go ahead
and create three different components
and
separate the code into these three
components and just add the custom html
tags in your home component
i'm just hoping you're following me
right now
and also here in my assets folder i've
added
a video and the youtube logo that needs
to be displayed
when the home icon is clicked
all right so now that we've created the
home and the login components
the next step is to configure the routes
for the application
all right so here you can see that we
have a file called app routing module.ts
file
so here
we have the routes and the router module
that is imported
and we also have a constant called
routes which is strongly typed to routes
from the router package
all right now this array is used to
define all the possible routes in the
application now each route is basically
an object with a path
so here in my routes array
i'm just going to go ahead and create
the paths that is we have two different
routes right one is for login and one is
for home
so i'm just going to create a path
object so let's say path
i'm sorry within curly braces i say path
[Music]
and then the path that i'm going to give
is
login
this is basically what will appear
on the url all right
and the component that needs to be
navigated to is nothing but the login
component
so let me just say login
component
as you can see the login component has
been automatically imported
now same with
the home path so let me just say
path
home
and the component that needs to be
rendered is the home component
[Music]
all right
now the next step is to link these
routes to a button
in the navbar that is the home and the
login button right so we're going to
make use of the nav tag and an anchor
tag for this
you can see that we have a nav
tag and an anchor tag
which encloses the login and the home
components
all right now we're going to make use of
two directives
from the router package called router
link and router link active
now these are specified within the
anchor tag
the router link basically holds the path
to the page
and the latter that is the router link
active specifies one or more css classes
that will be applied when the router
link is active
all right so to do that let me just
add
router
link
all right in our case it is home here
and we're going to have another
director called
router link active
[Music]
and we're just going to say
active here
[Music]
all right
same for the login icon here
let me just copy this
[Music]
and instead of home
the path we created for this was login
all right
so this is how you can
bind the route to your specific button
on your ui
now despite of all this
how are we specifying where these
components are to be displayed
right the answer to this is using the
router outlet directive now again this
directive is available in the router
package
so we have to add that in our app
component.html file
so here just go ahead and type
router
outlet
all right
so with that we've created a simple
navigation bar which has different
options that is home about services and
link and once the user clicks on the
home icon it displays the content that
is in the home component dot html file
and once the user clicks on the login
component it displays the content in the
login.html file
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's go to the browser and see
if it executes correctly
so all right we have the navigation bar
and once i click on the home i can hear
all right yes we see that all the
content has been loaded
you can see we have uh the intro section
we have the courses section and the
footer section as discussed
and the most important part is that here
in our url you can see that slash home
has been appended this shows that a
route has been created that navigates to
the home component so we've successfully
created a route here
and for login component when i click on
this icon
you can see that the path changes here
and the login component gets displayed
right so this is how routing is achieved
in angular choose from over 300 in
demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
in this session we'll be comparing the
three cutting-edge ui development
technologies that is react.js angular
and vue we learn about the key
differences that make them so distinct
all of these technology stacks have been
replacing pure server-side technologies
and we've slowly progressed from
server-side applications to more
distributed applications where a part of
the job is done on the client side and
apart on the server side and now we've
transitioned to something known as
single-page applications or sba and all
of these technologies that you see on
your screen right now are based purely
on javascript as a result they're
lightweight and aren't dependent on any
third-party runtime tools so let's
compare the three technologies and learn
about the factors that make them stand
out so let's see what's in it for you we
learn about their features use cases and
where they're applied their performance
how they handle data the languages they
use and the testing mechanisms we learn
about the dedicated user community that
backs these technologies and finally
we'll see the growth curve first we'll
look into the saline features now react
is a front-end javascript library while
angular and vue are javascript
frameworks now although the terms
library and frameworks are used
interchangeably they're significantly
different now library is a set of
classes or functions and the user is in
complete control to call them frameworks
on the other hand are like models they
have limited choices and come with a
blueprint of their own and as a result
the user doesn't have much control so
javascript being an interpreted language
where code is executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment and would definitely
encounter a delay now these are avoided
and as a result these tools are fast
moving on react is used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single page applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack mainly because it's
purely based on css html javascript and
jquery single page applications as the
name suggests are built using single
page now the entire page is broken down
into several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component handles the
login the other one would display icons
and images and so on all these bits or
components are then put together to form
a single page application and moving on
react was developed and maintained by
facebook while angular was built by
google and view was developed by evan
unx google employee now react represents
the view part of the mvc framework and
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
in itself and view on the other hand is
focused on view and the model layer of
the mvc framework now what exactly is
the mvc framework now mvc framework is
an object-oriented design principle that
mandates the separation of control
meaning one thing can only do one thing
so the model deals with the entity
classes the data and the business logic
while view deals with the representation
and the ui logic of the application and
the controller drives the functionality
of the two any changes can be easily
factored and isolated and as a result
testing becomes a whole lot easier
moving on now let's look at the use
cases from the business perspective in
terms of react we have top websites like
facebook instagram netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by nike hbo forbes sony and
vue is commonly used by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an html view and render it into
the browser this view to the user is
basically just html tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balanced tree
structure this b3 algorithm is extremely
fast so when the user makes any changes
to the ui the changes are reflected
immediately this is facilitated by the
b3 algorithm so as a result the
performance is improved so how does
react make use of this tool it uses a
virtual dom dom is an api developed by
w3c it stands for document object model
and defines how the document is accessed
and manipulated this dom parser converts
the html code into an inverse balance
tree structure so react uses the virtual
dom while angular uses the real dom and
vue uses the virtual dom again now the
virtual dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
html pages and only changes the parts
that need to be updated angular on the
other hand updates the entire tree
structure regardless of any changes made
or not and view again only updates the
ones that have changed since there is no
time spent on making unnecessary changes
to the entire tree react is extremely
fast on the other hand real dom updation
is time consuming risky and error-prone
vue also ensures faster and bug free
performance now let's talk about data
binding the core reason why we would use
single page applications now consider a
scenario where you log into an
e-commerce website as say user one then
you should be able to see the items in
your shopping cart while user 2 would be
seeing different items in their shopping
carts and so on so identifying the user
and retrieving data corresponding to
that specific user is facilitated using
the help of data binding data binding is
a process that allows an internet user
to manipulate web page elements using a
web browser now it is used in
interactive components such as
calculators tutorials games etc now
react supports one way data binding
meaning you can take the data from the
view and push it to the model or vice
versa angular on the other hand uses a
two-way data binding while view also
uses a similar two-way data binding in
react every time the model state updates
the view changes accordingly however the
reverse is not true in case of angular
any changes made to the view are
immediately reflected in the model part
of the architecture view follows the
same principle now this hugely
influences the performance due to
one-way data binding react is modular
and fast improving the performance
angular's two-way data binding adversely
affects the performance and view on the
other hand performs according to the
input type moving on to scripting
languages react combines ui templates
and javascript logic resulting in a new
language called jsx so react only
requires the knowledge of javascript
angular uses templates again in html you
can also inject javascript code into
html using a clever implementation in
angular called directives so you can
create a class and then inject it into
html angular also does something better
you can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax now vue again uses html based
template it uses html5 throughout for
the ui and the combination of javascript
for business logic all view templates
are valid html and can be passed by html
parsers let's move on to testing now
jest is a framework or an api that is
developed by facebook and is used to run
tests on react applications to ensure
that they are bug free now it is
embedded typically in every react
library and requires zero configuration
now angular on the other hand uses the
jasmine framework now this framework
allows various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases this also
ensures that the application is error
free the view cli or the command line
interpreter has built-in options for
unit testing with the help of jest or
mocha now vue typically has single file
components and hence these components
can be tested in isolation this makes it
modular and extremely fast now let's
talk about community support since all
these tools are open source they have a
large developer community there are a
few popular github repositories for
react such as react.js 101 react.js.org
and so on you can raise queries solve a
few and connect with the larger
community that's working on react here
are a few repositories for angular view
also has a few popular repositories you
can commit download third party plugins
and also explore these stacks even
deeper all of them surely have a very
happening community at the time of
writing there were about 1 million
repositories 5 million comments and 1
million issues with respect to react
here are the figures for angular and
here are the figures for view according
to npm stat over the past two years
there have been approximately 360
million react.js downloads there have
been around 38 million downloads for
angular and around 63 million downloads
for view now let's look at the future
scope learning a new technology always
comes with questions like what's in it
for me what's its growth potential how
far will it take me in my career and so
on so let's go ahead and see the growth
rate of react angular and vue according
to google trends over the past 12 months
react has been on a way faster upward
trajectory than angular and vue which
have considerably lost their momentum
now this indicates that react is growing
faster than the other two with respect
to popularity industry adoption and
community support in this video i
present to you some commonly asked
angular interview questions
now let's begin
i've classified the questions into two
sections
one is the beginner level questions and
one is the advanced level questions
so now let's begin with beginner level
questions
starting with the most basic what
exactly is angular
now angular is an open source javascript
front-end framework which is completely
written in typescript
this framework brings a structure and
consistency to web applications and
provides excellent scalability and
maintainability
now it's primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by google
it uses html syntax to express your
application's components clearly it is
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms
next up is what exactly is typescript
now typescript is a superset of
javascript that offers excellent
consistency
it is highly recommended as it provides
some syntactic sugar and makes the code
base more comfortable to understand and
maintain
ultimately typescript code compiles down
to javascript that can run efficiently
in any environment now typically
typescript is installed as an npm
package and thus can be installed with
the following command that is npm
install hyphen g typescript
moving on to our third question
what exactly is data binding and which
type of data binding does angular deploy
now data binding is a phenomenon that
allows any internet user to manipulate
web page elements
now it generally uses dynamic html and
does not require any complex scripting
or programming
we use data binding in pages that
contain interactive components such as
forms calculators
tutorials and games
data binding makes incremental display
of a web page more convenient
when it comes to angular it uses the
two-way data binding
any changes made to the user interface
are reflected in the corresponding model
state
conversely any changes in the model
state are reflected in the ui state
this allows the framework to connect the
dom to the model data via the controller
next question what are single page
applications
single page applications are web
applications that load just once with
new features just being mere additions
to the user interface
it does not load new html pages to
display the content
instead is generated dynamically
this is made possible through
javascript's ability to manipulate the
dom elements on the existing page itself
an spa approach is faster thus providing
a seamless user experience
differentiate between angular and
angularjs
now here's a simple table for you
so here are the features that we're
going to differentiate
the 2 on the basis of
first is language angularjs uses
javascript while angular uses typescript
when it comes to architecture angularjs
supports the model view controller
design while angular uses components and
directives angularjs is not supported by
mobile browsers
while angular supports all mobile
browsers
angularjs does not support dependency
injection while angular does
when it comes to routing at route
provider is used to provide routing
information in the case of angularjs and
in case of angular at route
configuration is used to define routing
information
when it comes to management angularjs is
difficult to manage with an increase in
source code size
while angular is better structured easy
to create and can manage bigger
applications
next up what are decorators in angular
decorators are a design pattern or
functions that define how angular
features work
now they are used to make prior
modifications to a class service or
filter
angular supports four types of
decorators namely class decorators
property decorators method decorators
and parameter decorators
next question mention some advantages of
angular first up is custom components
now angular enables users to build their
own components that can pack
functionality along with rendering logic
into reusable pieces
this is achieved with the help of these
components
data binding as discussed earlier
angular enables users to effortlessly
move data from javascript code to the
view and react to users events without
having to write any code manually
angular supports dependency injection
which enables users to write modular
services and inject them wherever they
need it
when it comes to testing tests are first
class tools and angular has been built
from ground up with testability in mind
you will have the ability to test every
part of your application and that is
highly recommended
next up is comprehensive angular is a
full-fledged framework and provides
out-of-the-box solutions for server
communication routing with your
application and more
lastly angular is cross-platform and
compatible with multiple browsers an
angular application can typically run on
all browsers be it chrome firefox safari
and operating systems like windows mac
os and linux
what's new with angular 10 first up is
that older versions of typescript are
not supported
previous versions of angular supported
typescript 3.6 3.7 and even 3.8 but with
angular 10 typescript bumped to
typescript 3.9
warnings about common js imports now
logging of unknown property bindings or
element names in templates is increased
to the error level which was previously
a warning
angular now supports an optional strict
setting which offers a stricter project
setup when you create a new workspace
there's an addition of ngcc features
with the program based entry point
finder there are common compiler updates
and updated url routing
angular 10 has several deprecated apis
that were previously redundant
with angular 10 version there have been
a number of bug fixes important ones
being the compiler avoiding undefined
expressions and the core avoiding a
migration error
new default browser configuration
browser configuration for new projects
has been upgraded to outdo older and
less used browsers
next up is core all the warnings will be
now logged in as errors
next update is converting pre-iv code
now all the pre-iv dependencies from npm
should be transformed to iv dependencies
which is supposed to take place as a
precursor to running ngtsc at the
application
and lastly we have service workers for
the service worker a fix has been put in
for a situation in which there was a
chance that the service worker would not
register when there is a long running
task or a recurring timeout
next up
is what are templates in angular
now angular templates are written with
html that contains angular specific
elements and attributes
now in combination with
model and controllers information
these templates can be rendered to
provide a dynamic view to the user now
templates are a very predominant feature
of angular that describe how information
can be displayed in the view
next question is what are annotations in
angular
now these annotations are used to create
an annotation array
they are basically the metadata set on
the class that is used to reflect the
metadata library
what are directives in angular
directives are attributes that allow the
user to write new html syntax specific
to their applications
now these execute whenever the angular
compiler finds them in the dom
now again angular supports three
different types of directives there are
component directives attribute
directives and structural directives
next up what is aot compilation and what
are some of its advantages
now aots that stands for ahead of time
compiler basically converts the angular
html and typescript into javascript code
during the build phase
that is before the browser downloads and
runs the code
so basically all the html and typescript
code is converted to javascript during
the build phase which means no
additional time is spent on converting
it into javascript later during the run
phase right so when it comes to
advantages
of course there's faster rendering
there are fewer asynchronous requests
it has smaller angular framework
download size
there's quick detection of errors and
this also offers better security
moving on to the next question what are
components
now components are the most basic
building blocks of the ui in an angular
application
now every component is associated with a
template and is a subset of directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template
now an angular application typically
consists of a root component which is
basically the app component and then it
branches out into other components
creating a hierarchy
now every component is decorated with
the help of at component decorator which
provides additional information
and component must belong to the ng
module
lastly components implement something
called the life cycle hooks you will
learn about them a little later in the
video
next up what are pipes in angular
now pipes are simple functions that are
designed to accept a particular input
value
process this value and return an output
which is a transformed value
now angular supports several built-in
pipes however you can also create custom
pipes that cater to your needs
but to speak about a few saline features
pipes are defined using the pipe symbol
pipes can be chained with other pipes
and pipes can be provided with arguments
by using the coenzyme
next up what are pure pipes
now these pipes are pipes
that use pure functions
as a result of this a pure pipe doesn't
use any internal state and the output
remains the same as long as the
parameters passed stay the same angular
calls a pure pipe only when it detects a
change in the parameters being passed
now a single instance of a pure pipe is
used throughout all components
next up what are impure pipes
now for every change detection cycle in
angular
these impure pipes are called regardless
of the change in the input fields
as long as there's a change detected
these pipes are called
as a result multiple pipe instances are
created for these pipes
now inputs passed to these pipes can
also be mutable
by default all pipes are pure however
you can also mention impure pipes using
the pure property
now here's a code for
specifying impure pipes you can use the
pure property and either mention true or
false true meaning it's a pure pipe and
false indicates that it's an impure pipe
next up what is the pipe transform
interface
now as the name suggests the interface
receives an input value
and transforms it into the desired
format with a transform method
it is typically used to implement custom
pipes
now here's again a small piece of code
now you can see that the pipe transform
interface is being used which in turn
executes the transform method now this
transform method is the one that is
responsible to change your input and
give a transformed output
moving on what is ng module
now ng modules are basically containers
that reserve a block of code to an
application domain or a workflow
now the at ng module takes a metadata
object that describes how to compile a
components template
and generate an injector at runtime
in addition to this ngmodule also
identifies the module's components
detectives services pipes and also
ensures that it makes them public so
that external components can use them
all of this is taken care of by the ng
module
next up what are filters in angular
now filters are used to format an
expression and present it to the user
they can be used in view templates
controllers or services
now to name a few
there's
date filter which formats a date to a
specified format
there's filter filter that selects a
subset of items from an array
there's the json filter which formats an
object to adjacent string
there's limit 2 which limits an array or
a string into a specified number of
elements or characters
then there's lowercase which formats a
string to lowercase
and so on moving on to the next question
what is view encapsulation in angular
now
view encapsulation basically defines
whether the template and styles defined
within the component can affect the
application or vice versa
angular provides three encapsulation
strategies
there's emulated encapsulation which
means that the styles from the main html
propagate to the component
then there is native which indicates
that the styles from the main html do
not propagated the component meaning it
does not affect the component and lastly
there's none which means that styles
from the component propagate back to the
main html and therefore are visible to
all the components on the page
now this indicates any different types
of changes and how it is affecting the
entire application
moving on what are controllers now as
the name suggests controllers control
the data of angular applications
they are regular javascript objects and
the ng controller directive defines the
application controller
next question what do you understand by
scope in angular
now the scope in angular binds the html
that is basically the view and the
javascript that is the controller it is
also an object with the available
properties and methods required for your
application
now when you make a controller in
angular you pass the dollar scope object
as an argument
moving on to the most commonly asked
question explain the life cycle hooks in
angular
as discussed earlier every component in
angular has a life cycle
angular creates and renders these
components and also destroys them before
removing them from the document object
model
it is achieved with the help of these
life cycle hooks now let's have a look
at them
first up is ng on changes now this
responds when angular sets or resets
data bound input properties
ng on it
is a hook that initializes the directive
or a component after angular first
displays the data bound properties and
sets the components input
properties ng do check detects and acts
upon the changes that angular can't or
won't detect on its own
ng after content init responds after ng
projects external content into the
components view
ng after content checked response after
angular checks the content projected
into the component
ng after viewing it responds after
angular initializes the components views
and child views
ng after view checked responds after
angular checks the components views and
the child views
lastly there's ng on destroy which
cleans up just before angular destroys
the directive or the component
moving on to the next question what is
string interpolation in angular
now string interpolation is a one-way
data binding technique that is used by
angular
now it outputs the data from typescript
code to html view
it is typically denoted with the help of
curly braces and it helps display data
from the component to the view to help
you understand it's working i've created
a variable called name
here in my
app.component.ts file and
initialized it to simplylon and back in
my html file i've created
a heading tag a header tag which
displays the name of the company is
and i've interpolated here with the help
of double curly braces
so when i run the file the output looks
something like this the name of the
company is simply learn so this is how
string interpolation is achieved in
angular moving on to next question what
are template statements
template statements are properties or
methods used in html
for responding to user events
now with these template statements the
application that you create or you're
working on can have the capability to
engage users through actions such as
submitting forms or displaying dynamic
content
most common example is the button
tag the template here is delete hero
this method is called when the user
clicks on the button
so this brings interactivity to your
application
with that we come to the end of the
first section which included the
beginner level questions
moving on let's look at some advanced
level questions
what is the difference between ahead of
time and just in time compilation
now ahead of time compilation converts
your code during the build time before
the browser downloads and runs the code
in case of just in time compilation this
process is a way of compiling computer
code to machine code during the
execution phase
aot ensures faster rendering to the
browser
while just in time is basically a
dynamic compilation
in case of ahead of time compiling
the user should include the hyphen
hyphen aot option with the ng build or
ng server command
and jit compilation is the default
compilation when you run the ng build or
ng serve cli commands
next up explain the add component
decorator
now here's a simple screenshot of what
that component decorator encompasses
is it is basically a typescript class
that is used to create
components
this genre of class is then decorated
with the add component decorator
the decorator's purpose is to accept a
metadata object that provides relevant
information about the component
now the image above shows an app
component
which is a pure typescript class
decorated with that component decorator
the object that gets accepted by the
decorator provides properties like
template url selectors style urls
and many more now here the template url
property points to an html file defining
what you see on the application
moving ahead what are services in
angular angular services
perform tasks that are used by multiple
components
now these tasks could be data fetching
network connections or database
management among others
they perform all the operational tasks
for the components and avoid rewriting
of code
a service can be written once and then
injected into all the components that
use it
generally components are used to only
display information on the ui they do
not perform any other back-end tasks
to perform tasks like validating
information or network connections etc
you can make use of a service
one advantage is that this service can
be injected into multiple components
that make use of the same piece of code
with this you can avoid redundancy
moving on what are promises and
observables
now while both the components deal with
asynchronous events in angular
promises handle one such event at a time
while observables handle a sequence of
events over some time
so to give you a brief explanation
promises emit a single value at a time
while observables are only executed when
subscribed to them using the subscribe
method
now promises also execute immediately
after they are created and they're not
cancelable
while observables help perform
operations like for each filter retry
etc promises push errors to the child
promises and observables can be
unsubscribed to so that the listener
stops receiving further values
next up what is ng on init and how is it
defined
now again here's a small snippet of code
ng on init is a life cycle hook as we
discussed earlier and there is a
callback method that is run by angular
to indicate that a component has been
created
it takes no parameters and returns a
void type
so i'm sure you can see here in the code
it takes no parameters and returns a
void
next up explain the use of ng4 in a tag
or explain the ng for directive
now the ng for directive is basically
like a for loop it is used to build
lists and tables and html templates
so in simple terms this directive is
used to iterate over an array or an
object and create template for each such
element
now in the snippet you can see there is
let items in item list and then i have
string interpolated
the
variable item so let item here creates a
local variable that will be available
inside the template
of items indicates that we are iterating
over the items iterable
and the asterisk before ng4 creates a
parent template
next up what are template and reactive
forms so there are two different methods
to create forms we have the template
driven approach and we have the reactive
form approach
so let's have a look at them
in case of template driven approach the
conventional form tag is used to create
forms angular automatically interprets
and creates a form object representation
for this tag controls can be added to
the form using the ng model tag
multiple controls can be
grouped using the ng control group
module
now a form value can be generated using
the form dot value object and form data
is exported as json values
basic html validations can be used to
validate the form fields
in the case of custom validations
directives can be used
when it comes to reactive forms
this approach basically revolves around
data flows and propagation of change
now with reactor forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
reactive forms are code driven unlike
template-driven approach
reactive forms break the traditional
declarative approach and eliminate the
anti-pattern of updating data via the
two-way data binding method
typically reactive form control creation
is synchronous and can be unit tested
with synchronous programming techniques
moving on what is bootstrap how is it
added to angular
now bootstrap is a powerful toolkit it
is a collection of basic html css and
javascript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications
there are two ways to embed bootstrap
libraries
first up is using the bootstrap cdn
which is the content delivery network
now this enables users to load the css
and javascript files remotely from its
servers
the other way is to use angular
bootstrap via npm
now this
is used to add bootstrap to your angular
project by installing it into your
project folder
now you can use commands like npm
install bootstrap and npm install jquery
to install them for your project if you
wish to learn bootstrap in detail i
highly suggest you check out our video
on angular bootstrap the tutorial
explains how to embed bootstrap and user
to create and good looking angular
applications
what is eager and lazy loading
eager loading is the default module
loading strategy
now all the feature modules under eager
loading are loaded before your
application even starts
this is typically used for small size
applications since lesser modules are
used all of these modules are loaded
initially which makes
running of these kind of applications
extremely fast
when it comes to lazy loading
all the loading happens dynamically
all feature modules are loaded on demand
it is used for bigger applications where
the modules are not required at the
start of applications
this makes the application faster since
no time is spent on loading unnecessary
modules
next up what type of dom does angular
implement
dom or document object model
treats an xml or html document as a tree
structure
in which each node is an object
representing a part of the document
now angular uses the regular dom
this updates the entire tree structure
of html tags until it reaches the data
that has to be updated
now to ensure that the speed and
performance are not affected angular
implements something called as a change
detection
next up how is dependency injection
achieved in angular
now dependencies are objects or services
that a component needs to perform
functions correct now with the help of
dependency injection
these classes can request dependencies
from external sources rather than
creating them on their own here i've
created a service called demo service
using the command ngg service demo
service
and i've also added a small snippet of
code when you create that service
now these services can be injected to
your main component and perform various
functions
next up how does angular routing work
now i'm sure you must have observed that
the url changes every time you click on
your user interface on an application
correct every time you navigate through
the application or move from one page to
another the url changes
now this means that
the application is being routed or
you're navigating through the
application
so basically routing helps navigate
through a web application especially in
case of single page applications now as
discussed earlier single page
applications are loaded just once so any
new content that is being displayed is
just a mere addition it's not being
loaded again so routing plays a vital
role in case of single page applications
typically it is specified with the help
of the forward slash and followed by a
path that defines a new content
now i'm just taking the same example
that i took before
this was the example for string
interpolation however you can see that
we have a navigation bar here with four
different options for that is home about
services and login and for home and
login i've created
a path and added routing to it so when i
click on the home icon
you can see that
some content is being displayed onto the
screen and if you observe you can see
that there is
a forward slash with the path name home
here which indicates that routing has
occurred
same with login when i click on it the
path changes and the login page appears
if you wish to learn
the concept of routing i suggest you
check out a video the tutorial explains
routing in detail
moving on what are form control and form
groups
now a form control is basically a class
that enables validation
for each input field an instance of this
class is created
and these instances help check the
values of the field and see if they are
touched untouched dirty pristine valid
invalid and so on so for every field in
the form
the data that is being provided is
validated with the help of these
controls
if it is dirty it means that the value
has been changed if the data provided
holds good for a particular condition
then the
control is said to be valid and so on
with the help of these controls you can
determine if the value provided is
legitimate or not this can be achieved
with the help of form control
when it comes to form group
when the form group class represents a
group of controls
now a form
can have multiple control groups
the form group class returns true if all
the controls are valid and also provides
validation errors if any
next up is how is testing achieved in
angular
now angular uses jasmine to run various
tests
the jasmine framework allows various
functionalities to write different kinds
of test cases the task runner for these
tests is typically karma
and karma uses a configuration file to
set the startup reporters and the
testing framework
next question is what is package.json
now npm installs package.json when a new
workspace is created
now this file includes a starter set of
packages some of which are required by
angular
now typically it's organized into two
groups one is dependencies these are
essential to run your applications
and we have dev dependencies these are
essential to develop applications so
with that we come to the end of this
video
i hope it helped you get a good hold of
angular fundamentals if you have any
doubts or queries let us know in the
comment section below thank you so much
for being here and watch out for more
videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn